une nouvelle journée de tension en
perspective la commission électorale
doit annoncer ce soir au plus tard
demain les résultats de l'élection
présidentielle hier allaient débuter
l'annoncé des résultats partiels
département par département et on a pu
observer
d'ailleurs un renforcement sécuritaire
ici dans la capitale économique abidjan
c'est donc le signe que l'annoncé de ses
résultats approche à grands pas si le
nom du vainqueur ne fait guère de doute
ça devait être le président sortant est
bien les ivoiriens espèrent que dans les
heures qui vont précéder et succès dès
l'annoncé des résultats
eh bien le pays ne bascule pas dans un
nouveau cycle de violence c'est vrai que
la crise post électorale de 2010 et 2011
qui a fait 3000 morts et bien elle est
encore très présente dans les esprits
dans les régions du nord
le 31 octobre jour de scrutin c'est vrai
que tout s'est bien passé en revanche
dans les régions du sud
ce n'est pas du tout le cas plusieurs
régions ont été empêchés de voter
il y a eu des barrages des
manifestations pour perturber les
opérations de vote
cela même perdurer pour empêcher la
remontée des résultats une situation
très tendue
encore hier en tout cas pour
l'opposition
et bien c'est une victoire elle
revendique une victoire elle qui a
appelé à la désobéissance civile
il y aurait plusieurs morts et pascal
affi n'guessan le leader du front
populaire ivoirien d'une frange en tout
cas de ce parti fondé par laurent gbagbo
est bien lui il parle d'une trentaine de
morts ce sont des chiffres à prendre
avec des pincettes c'était lors d'une
conférence de presse hier dans l'après
midi à la résidence d'henri konan bédié
l'ancien président ivoirien du pdc y sur
les quatre candidats en lice on le
rappelle ce pascal affi n'guessan et
henri henri konan-bédié et bien eux
n'ont pas voté
affi n'guessan pascal affi n'guessan a
dénoncé une violation constitutionnelle
il a dénoncé aussi des irrégularités
appelé à une transition civile à la fin
du mandat d'alassane ouattara qui
techniquement c'est vrai cette hvl
samedi à minuit la veille le rhdp avait
tenu à rassurer le pays sur le bon
déroulement du scrutin comme l'ont fait
d'ailleurs la commission électorale et
la plupart des missions d'observation
africaines
on observe donc une guerre de
communication qui ne fait que commencer
entre l'opposition et le pouvoir pour
défendre ou décrédibiliser ce scrutin